merci d'être avec nous 20h44 on est en
direct touche pas mon poste j'espère
passe un bon moment parce qu' on rigole
énormément on parler de la sortie de
Cameron diz les couples mariés devraient
dormir dans des chambres séparées
êtes-vous d'accord avec elle non moi je
suis pas d'accord avec elle du tout on
Quême canard le
canard cy vous nous confier il y a
quelques instants vous étiez fort avec
tout le monde mais que vous étiez tendre
ouais un géant de
papier un colosse au pied
d'argile c'est hyper
émouvant ça va vous rendre
humain d'habitude les gens disent vous
êtes une tête de con là au moins ils on
quel chose enquête va faire un correctif
dites quelque chose bon alors déjà
pourquoi vous êtes pas d'accord par que
il nous a je dire vous savez ce qu'il a
fait à la pub il a enregistré sa meuf en
train de ronfler il nous l'avit fait
écouter c'est
horrible pour montrer à la fille
excuse-moi respecter ouais non je
parlais de camandias voula raconte mon
anecdote avec camandias non pas vasy
vas-y ah d'accord ok non non il se
trouve que il y a quelques années je
connaissais une copine qui était qui
travaillait dans une boîte libertine à
Paris où je ne vais jamais ma maman je
je ne vais jamais mais elle travailler
là-bas et elle me dit viens ce soir il y
a une star américaine je suis une star
américaine moi je pensais à un homme bon
n'importe quoi voilà elle me dit l'agent
de la star est passé 7 après-midi pour
s'assurer que dans la boîte parisienne
qui est dans le ver palais royal ils
éteignaient la caméra à l'entrée de la
boîte et à juste à l'entrée sur le
trottoir et à l'entrée là où il y a la
caisse voilà pour qu'il y ait pas de
trace de son passage et je n'y suis pas
allé et l'Ain elle m'a rappelé en me
disant tu es vraiment un con tu aurais
dû venir je dis pourquoi elle me dit
c'était Cameron Diaz qui était dans la
boîte de nuit et elle était deux gardes
du corps qui désigner les plus beaux
mecs de la boîte qui venaient et non
mais tu tu tu es sûr que cétait pas
Cameron Jaz non cétait Cameron diz c'est
Cameron diz qui est parait-il très
gourmande c'est
Camon
et et la semaine suivante il y avait un
petit cancart dans un magazine People où
c'était écrit camandias de retour de
Cann s'est arrêté dans une boîte
libertine parisienne où elle a désormais
ses habitudes donc Cameron Diaz je
l'embrasse j'ai raté la première fois si
elle revient qu'elle me fascine je
viendrai non non mais tu te fous de
notre gueule mais c'est vrai pourquoi je
raccontré ça je suis pas débile ça va
être repris dans la presse vous savez
que moi un jour un jour je suis allé
dans une dans une boî échangiste pour un
reportage et ben il y avait béber le
frelon
donc toi mais qu'est-ce que tu dis oui
toi tu parles ça fait 45 ans que tuas
pas de mec c'est vrai je m'aperçois j'ai
une nuit dans avec une nuit entière quoi
parce que
comme si tu kiffes ta meuf tu as envie
de dormir avec elle si tu kiffes pas ta
meuf tu as envie qu'elle se barre c'est
pas mal aussi les retrouvaill pour pour
faire crac craque et puis après on c'est
nul ça mais c'est tu kes pas ton mec ça
réduit le couple juste à à la sexu
ch c'est vrai ça rien à voir le même
r truc de
ou'est-ce que j'ai dit vous avez dit que
vous avez voilà que que pour votre
amoureuse vous
étiez raison qui
Fa c'est rien de
oufous Gill d'abord ch pas non mais moi
ça fait 11 ans que je suis un canard
donc je suis très heureux donc toi c'est
ta meuf qui veut pas dormir avec toi fr
heureux meuf elle dort jamais avec toi
bah c'est-à-dire que très souvent je
dors sur le canapé mais parce que on
s'embrouille ou tout ça mais sinon par
choix on dort ensemble mais dès qu'on
s'embrouille canapé donc pour la
séparation pour moi c'est le symbole du
clash du conflit et cetera en harmonie
qui est euh on fasse l'amour ou pas on
est dans le même lit voilà donc je suis
d'accord avec vous Cyril et maintenant
j'aimerais que vous racontiez votre
histoire qui les
mêmesir à préciser quand même que les
propos de JeanMichel mer suram bienû
nengage que lui c'est certainement une
énorme connerie comm comme il a
l'habitude d' dire pas illégal
[Rires]
d'érule
stop
St mais ferme ferme
vraiment pour conneries je va pas me
lâcher je lâcher je vais te donner un
conseil oui
fermeraim ça fait 14 ans
conse Cameron c'est n'importe
quoi pas
illég roulé dans la farine c'était pas
elle c'était un ch mais cétait un j'ai
pas dit un truc de ouf c'était un
travesti tu es sûr c'était pas Cameron
Jaz non non mais n'importe quoi ça nous
est égal mais vous alors non mais juste
pour préciser poisson les propos de
JeanMichel bien sûr dans que lui c'est
des énormes conneries bien entendu Camon
jazz dans un club échangiste il a jamais
échanger même quoi que ce soit j'ai
jamais vu échanger même quelque chose
des cl jamais qu'est-ce qu' a
elle a jamais rien échangé cam donc
fermela ferme qu'est-ce que je fais là
oui c'est vrai non mais c'est bon alors
voilà bon alors êtes-vous d'accord avec
elle le
sondageage le sondage le sondage le
sondage ouais c'est serré les mecs c'est
serré c'est serré c'est serré c'est
serré c'est serré mais moi voilà allez
mais c'est rien c'est pas un truc de ouf
plus vous attendez plus ça devient non
mais c'est vrai c'est nul je vous le dis
c'est nul mais soyz
tout je vous expliquer non moi la vérité
moi moi je je k fais dormir avec ma meuf
c'est normal l'over oui ah oui je
chement si tu dors pas avec ta meuf
c'est que tu la kiffes pas je te le dis
il y a des meufs a des meufs que qui é
comme ça envieéit pas ça la question
qu'on vous voulez dire quoi en fait le
truc de canard que tu faiszir quoi si je
te mets en cuillère avec ma
M non pas du tout moi je kiffais un truc
c'est moi moi quand je partais le matin
je kiffais euh quand ma meuf dormait je
je faisais un petit bisou pour avant de
partir oh c'est mignon nous en fume tout
le monde ça c'est pas canard ça et je
faisais un truc sur le front jeembrassé
sur le front et j'ai embrassé euh les
pieds
euh le SIF le SIF
arrête
taeule son
robot mon robot son robot mon robot
tu vois pas qu'on tient plus donne lui
son robot il va tout [__] en l'air
là
imagin fermela fermela bordel bon allez
on va revenir j'en peux plus aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je peux plus mais ça suffit
je ne dirai rien je dir rien je ne dirai
rien pas la bonneion m embre voilà je
dir rien je vous le dirai demain voilà
on doit passer à un autre sujetok on
ouvre l'émission avec demain oui on
ouvre l'émission
ave non mais franchement mais ferme-la
sans charier c'est insupportable je mon
robot tout monde a un robot sauf moi non
on a
plus insupport plus personne de robot tu
suis un peu l'émission il vient
comprendre qu'on plus de robot il est
con comme une pendule il est incroyable
pas si de ma copine moi qu'est-ce qu'il
y a moi j'embrasse pas le SIF de ma
copine
qu'est-ce que tu es con non mais
franchement tu es insupportable bon